David, why not tell Republicans not to vote?
They're voting for absolutely horrible people.
And again, it's the principle.
This is not a program that activate that advocates
for not voting.
And I understand if Republicans stopped voting,
then the left could easily win.
But it's if you know me, you know that that's
not how I operate.
I know that many will say, why aren't you
stooping to their level?
They stoop to their level and they don't care.
Well, I do care.
I do care.
I'm taking the high road on that.
But if Republicans want to insist that they
shouldn't vote because it's rigged, by all
means, go ahead and do it.
And I would gladly accept Republicans losing
those two seats because they believe that
their voting is actually rigged.
Go ahead.
But in the end, I think most Republicans are
going to vote.
Hey, David, are Democrats going to get destroyed
in twenty, twenty two, as most new parties
in the White House do during their first midterm
election?
So we have a lot of different things.
There's a lot of sort of milestones that will
be part of the twenty, twenty two midterm
elections.
First of all, these will be the first midterms
after the removal of Donald Trump.
In many ways, Donald Trump was sort of a crossing
of the Rubicon.
It was a before and after that, we will all
remember in American politics.
And so now that Trump has been removed, is
in the process of being removed, I believe
that there is some uncertainty as to what
we would expect in the first non Trump era
midterms.
Number two, twenty twenty two will be the
first election with the newly drawn districts
of the twenty twenty census.
Number three, it is true that the party out
of the White House tends to do well in their
first midterms.
But I actually do think that the twenty twenty
two midterms could be midterms where the Democratic
Party does well, even though it wouldn't really
line up with the historical trends.
So there's a couple of different things going
on here.
First of all, if Joe Biden gets a second coronavirus
stimulus passed and starts getting us out
of the pandemic, which will, of course, be
helped dramatically by vaccines that are soon
to be approved, and we see cases and deaths
declining significantly in the second half
of twenty twenty one and into twenty two.
And we really see what feels like a return
to normal by standard measures.
The economy does well, unemployment continues,
decreasing significantly, GDP recovers, etc.
You could really see Democrats do very well
in twenty, twenty two, much like Republicans
did well in the first midterms after 9/11.
In 2002, Bush had post 9/11 and did well in
those midterms.
Biden could be the post covid president and
Democrats could actually do very well in twenty
twenty two.
The other signal, and this is so early, I
mean, we're we're getting to the end of the
year.
We're speculating here.
But it's so early to really be thinking about
this if we continue seeing this slight shift.
Among suburban voters from the Republican
Party to the Democratic Party, that could
be a big factor, again, depending on what
redistricting looks like on the basis of this
year, census Biden's twenty twenty two suddenly
doesn't look nearly as bad or risky as many
first term presidents.
Obama 2010 comes to mind.
Obama 2010 was a disaster.
You had the Tea Party movement.
You had, yes, some racism that was reflexively
coming out in 2010.
You also have in the Senate, Democrats don't
have as many tough seats to defend in 2022.
They will have to figure out the seat held
by Mark Kelly because that's up again in twenty
twenty two, I believe.
I hope I'm not wrong about that.
Republicans will have to defend seats in Ohio,
Wisconsin, Florida.
Those would be big fights.
And then you are going to have some likely
incumbent Republican retirements as well.
Could be Pennsylvania, could be North Carolina.
Chuck Grassley in Iowa could be a likely retirement.
He's an old, significantly older guy.
He could be.
Close to 90, right by 20, 22, so the Senate
map back in when was it?
Hold on.
Twenty seven.
Twenty eighteen.
I guess after the twenty eighteen midterms
I've been saying I see twenty twenty Senate
as very tough for Democrats.
I see twenty, twenty two Senate as more of
an opportunity for Democrats.
If they can just roughly hold or gain a little
bit in twenty twenty we may indeed be heading
in that direction.
So I think that there's a real chance that
Democrats actually do really well in twenty,
twenty two.
Too early to tell.
We'll be following it and that will be.
Let's get past the Biden inauguration.
Let's start decreasing the number of cases
and deaths from the virus.
Let's really focus on that.
And then we will get to twenty, twenty two.
There will be time.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pakman dot com coupon code available
never mandatory, but available at your discretion.
The coupon code fresh start all one word,
all lowercase saves you gobs of money on a
membership.
We will see you then.